is there a particular Cuisine that you
want more people in the world to like
know about or try that you think is like
personal progress in the white guy
Subway sandwiches
damn I I really want to just try more
Southeast Asian food but worldwide
everyone should know that's hard to say
um I still think to this day Greek food
is underrated no you don't like Greek
food no no Greek Greek food Greek food
is so hit or miss really and dude it's
all down to what's the [ __ ] sauce
they put on everything
um Suzuki yeah if that [ __ ] doesn't if
that if they didn't make that properly
the food none of the Food Works I mean
not making good Tzatziki at a Greek
restaurant is being like Oh we got
vinegar instead of soy sauce for your
sushi it's like you know it's like such
a staple that it's like if you [ __ ] up
at that point there's no going off I I
I've had him I've had some amazing Greek
food that I thought was so good but so
often so often Greek restaurants
outside of Greece are so [ __ ] it's like
whoever runs it just hates everyone
in the UK in the UK or I've been
anywhere else in Europe we have you know
I've gone to other places in like
American I've tried Greek food and it's
like I don't know what it is it's so hit
or miss really it's like Italian it's
you can normally rely on it to be decent
at least one or two items that you like
and there's always something and it's
and to be honest you you have to really
[ __ ] try to [ __ ] up Italian food yeah
I'm not saying that it's easy to make
but like at least the base ingredients
are pretty readily available and the
recipes aren't too complicated and like
you have to really be have awful [ __ ]
maybe I just had it good because in
Australia we have a lot of Greek
immigrants maybe like I feel like I've
been to like two or three Greek
restaurants in Sydney and they're all
[ __ ] bomb they were so good so good I
don't know this is like anecdotal I
think I've had the worst service
consistently in Greek restaurants really
I think so I've had the best service I
feel like a really a dude I don't know
is that like there was a Greek
restaurant it's not there anymore that
was like near my house and like we would
go there because it was quite expensive
and it's expensive to eat out in
Australia right we would go there for
like if it's like a family member's
birthday or if it's like a New Year's
thing or something like that some kind
of Celebration and we went so often year
after year that like the head chef and
like most of the people who worked there
just knew who we were yeah and we got
some of the best [ __ ] service ever
like I've never seen my dad tip in
Australia except for at this Greek
restaurant every time my dad's like my
man yeah she could have gone there yeah
and it's not there anymore I don't know
maybe I need to try some restaurant more
restaurants let's see there's some
recommendations I mean I haven't been to
Greece so I I don't know if I've had
like other things it's nice yeah
everything was really cheap I remember
that I remember the food was quite good
yeah but that that's what makes me want
to go because I had such a good
experience at Greek restaurants in
Australia literally on the other side of
the [ __ ] planet from Greece that I'm
sure the fooding actual grease is just
as good if not better yeah I like the
food grease it was good yeah I feel like
I need to try more like Greek Foods uh I
think there's one thing that I feel like
I don't gel with Greek food and it's
just unfortunate that I just don't
really like Feta cheese you know I'm not
you're not only feta I don't really like
Feta a lot of people don't yeah and and
that's it is it is a strong taste it is
it is it's like a very very good though
it is a very very strong taste a bit too
strong for you like palettes you like
lamb though right yeah I like lamb okay
yeah good Greek lamb bro sorry I'm not
Emily don't worry
yeah when I eat lime it tastes like
goat's cheese and I'm like what like
they I mean yes they come you know goat
cheese and and uh you know whatever it's
I'm like how the [ __ ] how the [ __ ] does
the mink taste like the goat I don't
trust someone who said Yuzu tastes like
lemon cleaner I don't like Yuzu that
much though I I but do you think it
tastes like lemon clean it's a very
strong taste I will admit I don't know
if it's I want to get Emily back on
because she's the only person I've met
that could like rival she is like put
together like holy [ __ ] every time she
comes out every time she like in private
or on [ __ ] Twitter every time like we
talk about food she'll say something
[ __ ] outrageous so I'm like I thought
I had bad things like I'm sorry I don't
I don't believe I heard what you just
said could you repeat that for sure
Emily told me she didn't like lamb and I
was like
what what do you mean you don't like
lamb and so I I I'm like you know what
maybe you've just had a really bad lamb
yes like in America I think they got
many good lamps all right yeah I don't
think it's fresh I don't think it's good
stuff I was like whatever let's I'll
take you to somewhere that is really
good lamb and Hokkaido it's pretty good
[ __ ] that place we went to oh you've
been there yeah the genius complex yeah
and I was like let's just try this it's
a different style you cook it on the
grill right yeah yeah that's so good you
get like veg on the side and it cooks
and I was like all right we'll try every
cup I'm gonna try a little bit of each
one because she was like I don't dislike
lamb I just don't think it's that good
yeah let's try it yeah and every single
one she's like there's like goat's
cheese and I was like
and then she's like I just I just think
beef is way better than this and I'm
like what
what it's like it's different foods
different occasions you know I I think I
don't know what it is does she not like
the gaminess of it maybe I think so
maybe yeah I I can't accept people don't
taste like chocolate
I understand if you don't like it for
the gaminess but not for the subtle
cheese flavor that it has which it
doesn't I don't know what she's on yeah
I don't know so yeah that was
frustrating but I like lamb a lot
obviously I'm Welsh I love life yeah but
I feel like a lot of times in Wales they
didn't really cook it very well all
right yeah I will say it was always lamb
chops as well yeah I will say like
comparing like lamb to beef beef is like
a lot harder to [ __ ] up yeah I feel like
lamb if you don't cook it correctly of
the meat quality is not good there is a
there is like a real strong aftertaste
that can be very off-putting with land
but when you get good lamb [ __ ]
incredible have you ever had someone ask
you
yeah how would you like your pork cooked
no no someone was like do you want your
pork medium rare and I was like what
it's like what do you want I'm like what
do you what do you mean so I went to um
uh a katsu Place katsu is uh breaded uh
pork and then like fried yeah um and
they were like do you want it rare or
medium rare or well done I was like what
what do you what do you mean it's
tonkatsu yeah yeah I was like isn't it
deep fried how do you do what I was like
what do you mean I was very confused and
they were like also it's pork you should
not be yeah so the chef was like we
recommend it medium rare and I was like
okay I guess I'll trust you because it's
your pork and you do this a lot yeah
I'll get medium rare and it was slightly
pink very slightly pink like like a
little bit of pink in the middle yeah
but it was bomb it was really [ __ ]
good and I was like is it safe yeah I
assume so otherwise I don't think they'd
be open if it was important isn't red
pork like kind of bad yeah I don't know
is it can we google this but then this
is also the country that also does like
raw chicken like it was when I say it
was the one I posted on Twitter that
picture the tattoo so like it was it was
clearly all white with just very dots of
pink in the middle so I assume they were
trying to cook it because often if
you've ever if you've ever come to Japan
and you have cheap katsu it's sometimes
it can be like fighting like it is
fighting a war you're like biting really
hard to kind of separate because the
chunks are normally quite big yeah so
you do kind of want to it's normally at
least a two-bider and sometimes it is
pretty hard to get through it and you're
like okay [ __ ] and maybe it makes sense
that it would be medium rare but it
worked it worked yeah it's a little bit
big it's okay it's a little bit pink
it's okay so that's probably why it was
good it was it was tasty highly
recommend it they have it was a chain
I'm sure it's gone but like I would also
be a little bit worried if the chef came
up to me said how would you like it I
was just I was taking her back because I
I never had that before it was like a
bog standard cut like corner street uh
katsu Place how you want your chicken
done here yeah I'm just gonna do can I
get my chicken
I I I I ordered it and I was like oh
well you know what do you what do you
mean like I'd never heard of Chef ask me
that and I thought he was saying
something else because I thought I
thought I misunderstood yeah because I
was like what the [ __ ] do you mean
medium rare what no I didn't get beef
yeah but now is that it was good I
recommend it so if you ever get if you
ever get asked in Japan how do you want
your tonkat to and if the guy recommends
medium rare trust him he knows what he's
talking about so so bottom line with the
Emily thing she tried all those
beautiful cuts of meat right A lot of it
was Australian Cuts as well if I
remember and there was deer there as
well
she liked the deal yeah yeah and then
she was like ghost she's in it I think
she just liked I think people just like
beef sometimes and I think some people
associate like beef in the uh sorry meat
in the head is chicken or beef and then
pork is somewhere in the middle but I
think some people when they've only
really eaten chicken and beef a lot they
kind of only really think about those
too and they think of things the white
mean there's a red meat and so every
flavor of meat in their mind is like a
tree that starts from chicken or beef so
I think like some kind of I think
there's some kind of thing when you just
don't eat yeah I mean it's like a mental
thing right away you try something new
mental death and you're just like
what did she expect when she said to the
Welsh person I don't like lamb and I was
like what do you no that's not allowed
it's because you've had [ __ ] laughs yeah
[ __ ] lamb but that's had good lamb man
apparently that didn't change I didn't
change your mind apparently at the end
of it she was like no she doesn't tastes
like goat cheese I'm like what the [ __ ]
is your palette what is this [ __ ] every
time someone's like allergic to dark
deathly allergic to food now I'm gonna
be like scalicious
[Music]
why why are we why do we just should
restart the game
what are they allergic to things why
does that happen do we know
why allergies happen yeah why would you
become allergic to [ __ ] skin issue
music
no one I don't understand more is how is
it that your body's just like yeah so um
you're allergic to this this and this by
the way so don't ever have it in your
body and then 20 years later they're
like never mind is it like you're good
now is it like a like a you know how
like games when they ship and there's
bugs like that where like it's like it's
like a patch I Feel Like It's gotta be
like some kind of bug on the DNA strand
well because like you are you are
allergic to this fruit that is nowhere
near where you are born and no one in
your ancestors have ever eaten you're
like what well because my my dad how did
that happen my dad was born with a prawn
allergy okay and then at the age of life
20.
one day he was just like yeah and then I
could eat it my allergy just went away
I'm like how does that work yeah I don't
get it yeah some people who are allergic
to like everything you're like what went
wrong like what happened how did you
just get allergic to everything like
well you developed an allergy to I
developed analogy to catch and and some
Breeze adults yeah skilled left dude
yeah
imagine not being able to pet every dog
I would end it I would be like I would
end it now I would just start again
I'm I'm smacking differently on this
country minus intelligence not allergic
to dogs
what's the point my happiness meter it
cannot cannot be full I've maxed out my
dog petting skill tree yeah I was just
[ __ ] man I need to tell him he's a good
boy
that's so [ __ ] stupid that's [ __ ]
up but he just thinks it's something
else it's like oh God you're dying it's
just a like a chicken wing
is anyone allergic to chicken
uh maybe you know we should do for trash
taste we should we should take one of
those allergy tests and then we should
report our results are we allergic to
any weird specific things oh yeah
because they can give you like a test
where they prick you with like every two
thousand different yeah yeah yeah yeah
and they're like all right look you're
allergic to octopus fangs
[Applause]
I used to be uh I used to get hay fever
and then I didn't and then I was just
like I don't know what happened I just
woke up one day and then I just did wait
wait so you had hay fever in the UK but
not here right no I had hay fever in the
UK yeah and then when I turned like 18
or something I just stopped having hay
fever really yeah I don't get in the UK
or anything anymore your body just
decided to be a giga chat
told my bodies to get good and it did so
it's like it's like when I hear about
people who like they they ate they they
ignored their lactose intolerance so
much that they just somehow stopped
being lactose intolerant I'm like you
sacrifice so much no but that that's an
actual thing that can happen it's like
because like you can also develop it if
you don't have enough Dairy rice but
also you can do the same thing with like
cats for example if you live with the
same cat that you started off as being
allergic to yeah and you just let your
immune system just fight that [ __ ] for
like I think it's like a couple of weeks
on average yeah it is true because
that's what happened to Chris oh okay
yeah Chris was allergic to cats but then
when Chris and Charles suddenly be
together she has a cat yeah and then he
had to live with this cat for you know
have him anyways after a while he's like
I'm not allergic to this particular cat
your body just learns to process that
particular cat's allergens or whatever
the [ __ ] it is
the cat hair constantly kept appearing
on here yeah
rookie mistake yeah but so like that
that is like one way that you can just
get over so it's really interesting in
the case with Chris it's that he's not
allergic to this one particular cat that
he lives with yeah but every other cat
he still allergic to huh and it's like
your body just being like yeah you're
good with this all these other ones
though no you're still [ __ ] being
allergic to these fruits and whatever
the [ __ ] any of this stuff yeah I could
I could live with that
but I couldn't be lactose intolerant man
I a world without cheese is one I don't
want to be in aren't we old technically
a little bit lactose intolerant no we
are I don't know if you would like toast
intolerant you would just take the L and
just like fight I would I would fight
this as the man who has food poisoning
every [ __ ] week you you you were just
like lactose
[Applause]
of like kids who are allergic to peanut
butter like [ __ ] it they eat like the
peanut butter uh the like Reese's
compliment just stabbed himself with the
Epic it's like I think I would be that
kid I would be like [ __ ] it
like sitting profusely on the toilet
seeing like the cheese risotto thing
they do where they they cook like they
put them like half the cheese I'm like
all right all right good enough load the
bidet ready I'm going in yeah like I
have some friends who live here who are
like full on lactose intolerant like
can't eat any Shades at all some days
when I'm out eating with them Asian
right they have yeah some days I'm just
out eating with them and they're just
like [ __ ] it like that looks too good
I'm just gonna take the hair so [ __ ]
Jesus so [ __ ] good I'm gonna be
shitty for a straw for the next two days
God I love that's the one thing I can
agree on with French people yeah
[ __ ] great
I love cheese sir I I would cry
profusely if I was like her as a Torah
yeah I would too I just don't think I
could do it I I don't think I could
continue I don't think so I'm just glad
I don't have a food allergy yeah you
know when you go to a restaurant and
you're like do you have any food
allergies no yeah
it's like David here
because I love food so much and I love
like so many variations of food that
like it would just be such like an
immediate hindrance to just like yeah
actually get explorative with food I
feel yeah and it sucks it must [ __ ]
suck but like you know I got some
friends with some peanut allergies where
it's like you have to go into a
restaurant as a [ __ ] battle because
you have to profusely make sure that
they know like hey I cannot have
anything with peanuts yeah peanuts you
cannot breathe near peanuts and walk
near me like they're and sometimes they
take it seriously and sometimes they
don't yeah yeah I mean it's unfortunate
um because I remember when I when during
my wedding you know obviously I had to
get everyone's dietary requirements oh
yeah and then everyone was just like
fine fine fine fine and then you know I
had one person have to like send me a
[ __ ] shopping list oh no you've been
this is what you have to live with a
friend in the UK who's uh allergic to
Sesame yeah
um but they're Asian
so so yeah they want to eat Asian food
how do they a lot of the time it's like
ah please please please don't put Sesame
in it then like they're like yeah of
course of course they use sesame oil a
lot of the times to cook yeah yeah just
forget yeah they get sick a lot